Herkese merhaba ben özgürce
konuya nasıl başlayacağım açıkçası
bilmiyorum Çünkü çok önemli bir
platformdayım sizlerin önündeyim
olabildiğince
hayatından örnekler verip bu hayatta
neler yapılabileceğini bu hayatta
size karşı gelen tüm olumsuzlukları
nasıl böyle olumlu bir şekilde
hayatınıza ekleyebileceğiniz
konular hakkında birkaç bir şey söylemek
istiyorum
2014 yılından önce paralimlik bir sporcu
değildim Aslında
2014'ten önce tekvando sporuyla
uğraşıyordum gayet sağlıklı
birey olarak
ancak
2014'ten sonra trafik kazası geçirdim
ailemle birlikte
kazada benim benim Kralı annemin de
boynu kırıldı
Tabii bu kaza anında iki kişinin
yaralanması hem fiziken hem de
psikolojik olarak bizi biraz etkiledi
uzun bir süre hastanede Fizik Tedavi
aldık
ve içimde hep şu vardı Ben spora ne
zaman geri döneceğim ya da dönebilecek
miyim çünkü en büyük hatamın paranın bir
araştırmamak olduğunu fark ettim
hastanede yatarken bir gün antrenör
geldi voleybol antrenörüydü ve babam
dedi ki spor yapmak ister misin dedim ki
Tabii ki ne olursa olsun yapmaya hazırım
çünkü buna açık
Daha sonrasında o toprak voleybolu
izlemeye başladım bildiğiniz bir parke
üzerinde Eller yardımıyla İleri
ve gif ile sizin boyunuzda normal
voleybol oynuyorsunuz tabi bunun farklı
kuralları var Uzun bir süre voleybol
oynadın Ama tabi benim 13 yaşından beri
spor yaptığım için hep hayalim milli
forma giymek milli formayı taşımak
ülkenin en iyi şekilde temsil etmek oldu
Daha sonrasında İstanbul'a geri dönüş
yaptığımda o tarak voleybol olmadığını
fark ettim o branşın olmadığını fark
ettim
çok büyük bir hayal kırıklığına uğradım
Daha sonrasında Tabii
dedim ki yani eğer oturarak voleybol
varsa başka paranın bitip branşlarda
İlla ki vardır
kendi branşımı seçemedim yani çünkü
tekvandoda daha farklı kurallar olduğu
için
okçuluğa vakfını okçulukla ilk kez
tanıştım
orada arkadaşlarım atıyordu Hatta
arkadaşlarım şey derdi O anta Ben onları
gördüklerimle ya onların atıyorsa ben de
yapıyorum demiştim Hala aralarında buna
gülüp Benim de dalga geçerler
çok uzun süre okçuluğa gidip gelmeye
başladım
Otobüsle gidip geldiğim zamanlar oldu
otobüsten düştüğüm zamanlar oldu
tekrar o sandalye oturup o otobüse binip
tekrar gittiğim zamanlar oldu antremana
yağmurda bekledim
Sırtımdan montu çıkaramadım
iki gün boyunca yatağın içinde
bacaklarımın ısıtamadığım anlar oldu ama
tek bir amacım vardı Kendi şifam bulmak
kendi şifamı aramak
Her şeyden önce şifa bedende değildir
ruhumuzda Eğer ruhunuz iyiyse mutluysa
ve her şey yolunda ise İnanın bana
bedeniniz Buna ayak uyduruyor
Şimdi en üzüldüğünüz anlarda Hep uyumak
isteriz hiçbir şey düşünmek istemeyiz
konuşmak istemeyiz hayata karşı bir
amacın olmadığını düşündüğünüz anda her
şeyi bitiyor
ama ben hep bir amaç uğruna kendime bir
amaç yaratarak
kendi şifamı aradım ve buldum
şu anda Okçuluk yapıyorum
2018'den bu yana ilk olimpiyat madalyemi
kazandım arkadaşlarım evi şeyler ya önce
dünya madalyası olur Avrupa madalyası
Olur Sen nasıl gidip işte ilk olimpiyat
madalyanı aldın
Ben her gece bunun hayalini kurdum
madalya'ya çıkışı hanımı insanları beni
alkışladığı o an işte böyle gülüyorum
ağlıyorum yani Düşünsenize ortada
Madalya falan yok bir başarı yok Sadece
gidip antrenmanımı yapıyorum saatlerce
çalışıyoruz iki günle birlikte çok fazla
emek sarf ediyoruz bir anda annem
Onun için bizim için okulunu bırakan
ablam
kardeşim hepsi bizim için bir emek sarf
ediyor
Gece yatağa yatıp o madalyayı aldığımı
düşünüyorum
kendi bedenimi ve ruhumu besliyorum
açıkçası Çünkü o gün için hazırlık
yapıyorum kendime ben
oldu madalyayı aldığım gün Ne hayal
ettiysem
ne yaşadıysan Hepsini orada tek tek
gerçekleştirdim Çünkü zaten ben onu
burada kazandım
burada yendim Burada aldım
ro madalyeyi alamasaydım Tabii ki
üzülecektim yani şimdi burada üzülmezdim
diyemeyeceğim
ama her şeyden önce verdiğim emeğe sahip
olacaktı
ben buna emek verdim
Demek ki verdik çaba sarf ettik Demek ki
bir tık ilerisi olması için çabalamam
gerekiyor diye daha fazlasını yapacaktık
ve bu sadece spor hayatında da değil
kendi hayatında birçok aşamadığın
noktalar oldu
sinir krizleri geçirdiği mallar oldu Hep
böyle değildim
ama her seferinde o anlarımı başka bir
günde gülerek anlattım
çünkü ondan ders çıkardım
hayatım bana verdiklerini
aldım
şimdi dedim
ve bir çözüm yolu buldum
Şu an hala Yolun Başındayım belki
olimpiyat madalyem var dünya madalyam
var Avrupa Şampiyonası madalyam var
Ama onların yerine daha iyisini
katabilmek için daha uygun çok
başındayım
annem için daha çok Yolun Başındayım
insanın hayatı
Sadece bir kere
Size gelen
Kötü bir durum olabilir
iyi bir olana olabilir Ne olursa olsun
Öncelikle araştırmaktan vazgeçmeyin Ben
2014'ten öncesine kadar normal sağlıklı
ve birey hiçbir şeyim yoktu
hayatımda gayet normaldi
Şu anda da normal
Çünkü ben istedim
ben nasıl olmasını istediysem
hayatım bu şekilde yönlendirdim
Tabii ki en büyük amaç ve destek bunu
yapabilmem için
alınan tüm yardımlar destekler
hem hiç söylediğim gibi birine örnek
olmak birine Umut olmak Benden
başkasının da ona geçeceği Ondan
başkasına bir başka birine geçeceğim
Belki şu anda burada beni dinleyen
birine dokunabiliyorum Belki de
Hayatımda birçok noktayı
değiştirebilecek
kendine karşı verdiği değeri daha da
yükseltebilecek ya da bulamadı ya da
Uzun sürede barış içinde olduğu
benliğini kendi içine çıkaracak
Bu amaçla her zaman hep şunu söylerim
aile çok önemli
aile bireyin
o çocukluk geçmişi çok çok önemli
benim Çocukluğum biraz fırtına geçmiştir
Biz Dört kardeşiz
kardeşin içinden en hırçını en yarımızı
işte hep şey düşünürdüm ya acaba Çok
hareketliydik Bak işte böyle oldu
diyenler mi dersiniz işte çok
hareketliydi birazcık da işte durulması
gerekiyor mu diyenler mi dersiniz hayır
öyle değil bu
benim hayatım
ve ben nasıl yaşamak istersen öyle
yaşıyorum inanın hepimiz böyleyiz
Hayat şartlarımız zor olduğu zamanlar
oldu anlatıyorum Otobüsle gidip geldiğim
zamanlar oldu
insanların beni almadığı beni kabul
etmediği anlar oldu
ilk zamanlarda onlara kızsan da
bir anda şöyle bir düşünce geliyor içime
ya onlar da benim gibi araştırmamış
olabilir
Onlar da belki de benim gibi bilmiyor
olabilirdi O yüzden ne yapmam gerekiyor
olabildiğince
madalya kazanıp
bu tarz konuşmalar yapıp insanlara
Aslında bunu çok normal olduğunu
panelin pil engellinin Aslında çok
normal bir durum olduğunu anlatıp
yadırgamamak
Aslında çok önemsememekte Hani yani
birinde mesela çok fazla ilgi
verdiğinize de onu incitebil
iyorsun ya da birine çok umursamaz
davrandığınızda da aslında bu dengeyi
kurmak Tamamen sizin elinizde ve benim
elimde
Mesela biri benim sandalyemi sürmek
istediğinde diyorum ki şu anda kendim
yapabiliyorum ama yanımda yürüyebilirsin
bana böyle eşlik edebilirsin ya da
birine ihtiyaç duyduğunda
rica ederek ve gülümseyerek Aslında
Ondan bunu istediğimi ona hissettirip ve
onun da Bunu yapabileceğini düşündürüp
Bu şekilde bir yolu izliyoruz Çünkü bir
çoğu insanımız ne yazık ki
şu dönemlerde yani Birine yardım
etmekten bile çekinir olduk hepimiz
öyleyiz ama dediğim gibi ikili iletişim
çaba Çok önemli çünkü biz yarışmalarda
çok farklı
branşlarda görüyoruz birçok insan
görüyoruz dedik ki Tokyo ki bilime
paralellik oyunlarında
inanamazsınız Ben de bir şey demiştim ya
bu kadar Engelliyim ben bir arada
görmedim ya diyorum bu kadar var mıymış
yani ellerin kolları olmayan insan Ben
düşündüm ben şaşırıyorum Çünkü yeni
görüyorum
her zaman gördüğüm bir şey değil ama
gördükçe de gurur duyuyorum bir insanın
uzvu olmadan
Kolları bacakları gözleri olmadan bu
hayatta var olabilmesi mükemmel
çünkü hep şey Deniz işte bugün bacağım
ağrıyor hiçbir şey yapamayacağım moralim
çok bozuk Allah'ın niye böyle değil
Aslında bedeniniz değil
ruhunuz
iyileşmek istiyor
Aslında sorun sizde değil
kendinizi
[Müzik]
istediğiniz yerde bulamadığınız anda
soktuğunuz o psikoloji
Yani ben 5 yıl önce şifamı kaptım bir
hayat arkadaşım var 5 yıllık nişanlıyım
bu hayatta hep bir şey derdik Ya ben
hayatta yapamam işte biriyle uzun bir
hayat Uzun bir yolculuk kuramam
bir insanların tepkisini şöyle olurdu ya
işte bu kız evde kaldı mıknatıs çevrene
var niye sandalyede diye işte hiçbir şey
yapamam diye
halin kendisinde insanlara bunun nasıl
gösterdiğin benim için önemli
sporunu yapıyorum evime girip çıkıyorum
çok aktif hayatın var artık dedim Daha
şeydir artık eve gir
artık gel
işte Ablam diyor ki Öznur ya bu gece geç
gelecek misin ya Bak kapıyı açmayacağım
Sana artık düşünün yani
evdeki bazen
[Müzik]
çok mutluluk duyuyorum Çünkü insan bazen
yorulmayı dahi özlüyor
Siz siz olun Bu hayatta hiçbir zaman
yorulmaktan kaçmıyorum inanın ve düşünün
Bu hayatta her zaman bir tık ilerisi var
hep olacak
Ben de kendiniz için sınanmayacaksınız
bu hayatta şu anda sadece ben
sınavmıyorum
ben annem
ablaların kardeşlerim hayat arkadaşım
antrenörüm kulübüm
Sanki benim de birlikte herkes Aslında
hayatını biçimlendiriyor bu konudan ders
alıyor Bu konu hakkında bilgileniyor
Düşünsenize Yani beni bir gün
sandalyeyle yardım eden biri
gördüğünde bundan çekinmeden de bilerek
yardım ediyor
ya da arkadaşlık kurmak istiyor
iyileşmek istiyor
bunun için Ben elimden geldiğince Her
anlamda her yerde olmaya çalışıyorum
liseden sonra okuyamadım
kazağa geçirdiğim için
hatta liseyi bitiremedim o yıl beni
sınıfta bıraktılar mecburi Ben bir yıl
sonra akülü arabamla Yaklaşık 15 km'deki
yolu gidip geldim ve Okulu bitirdim Daha
sonrasında liseye bitirdikten sonra
üniversitede okumak çok aklımda yoktu
çünkü o anda psikolojik olarak çok
yorgun olduğumu hissediyordum Aslında
ruhum
iyileştiremedim o anda ona o anda gücüm
yoktu
Ama şu anda üniversiteye başladım milli
sporcuyum
çok iyi giden bir düzenim var
Bu hayatta her zaman bana her zaman
mutlu olmanızı diliyorum Umarım bir gün
sizlerle şifanızı bulur bu hayatta hem
kendinize hem de çevrenize dokunursunuz
Çok teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]